[MUSIC PLAYING]
AARON ZEMACH: Since their
inception a decade ago,
Jukebox the Ghost have been
finding new and creative ways
to make exciting and
innovative piano rock music,
as well as create a diverse
and ever-growing fan
base through the
use of social media.
They've played over
1,000 live shows
across the US and the
world and have no intention
of slowing down anytime
soon, with their spring 2018
tour being their largest yet.
So everyone, please
welcome to the stage
Ben Thornewill, Tommy Siegel,
and Jesse Kristin of Jukebox
the Ghost.
[APPLAUSE]
Hey, guys.
Thanks for coming.
BEN THORNEWILL:
Thanks for having us.
Hi, everybody.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
AARON ZEMACH: So for
anyone who doesn't know,
you guys all met in college,
in Washington DC, right?
BEN THORNEWILL: Yeah.
AARON ZEMACH: So do you remember
the first time each of you
met the other people in the
band, what that was like?
BEN THORNEWILL: Yeah--
AARON ZEMACH: What
was the moment?
BEN THORNEWILL: I don't
know if there's a moment.
So Tommy's the new guy.
We met Tommy our sophomore year.
But Jesse and I lived by
each other freshman year,
and so we both showed up.
And Jesse was like
still a skater kid,
and I was like 5 foot 6" still
and wearing like, you know,
IZOD polos.
And it was awful, really.
But somehow we became friends
and started playing together.
And then Tommy put up a
flyer in the music department
our sophomore year.
TOMMY SIEGEL: Yeah.
I mean, I remember I put up a
flyer in the music department,
an.
You guys called
my landline, which
is really dating myself, here.
But that was like the last three
months that I had a landline.
And I just happened to be
around when you guys called.
So lucky, lucky pick up.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah.
So you each came at it from
a different sense of styles.
Ben, you're classically trained
as a piano player, right?
And Jesse, you have more
of a punk background.
And Tommy, I've been told you
wanted to be in a jam band,
is your--
TOMMY SIEGEL: A
sort of jam band.
Yeah, maybe.
Sort of.
Yeah.
I like guitar solos.
AARON ZEMACH: OK.
So coming at it from all those
different styles and genres,
why did you think,
in your heads,
that this would be like
the musical match that
would make it happen?
BEN THORNEWILL: I
don't think we did.
JESSE KRISTIN: We didn't, no.
BEN THORNEWILL: I
think it was just
like these are the guys that I
guess we're going to play with.
And we'll see what happens.
It wasn't like, ah, yes.
I found a punk drummer
and a jam band kid.
[LAUGHTER]
I got the band.
JESSE KRISTIN: I never thought
I'd end up in piano rock.
BEN THORNEWILL: Yeah.
TOMMY SIEGEL: I remember
the first practice we had,
thinking this is strange,
but it could work.
Maybe.
At some point.
That was my feeling.
I was like, these guys are
good, but there's no basis.
That's weird.
BEN THORNEWILL: I think
we still feel that way.
AARON ZEMACH: Like--
BEN THORNEWILL: Like
this is strange.
I guess we can keep doing it.
AARON ZEMACH: Mm-hmm.
So when you get in a cab in
the city with a guitar case
or drums and the taxi driver
says, oh, you're in a band.
What type of music do you play?
How do you describe it
to them, what you do now?
BEN THORNEWILL: Yeah, we
all look at each other.
Umm--
JESSE KRISTIN: I say
I'm in a rock band.
BEN THORNEWILL: Which is--
JESSE KRISTIN:
And that's simple.
BEN THORNEWILL:
Simple and misleading.
But I think-- I usually say
piano rock because that's like
an easy way to--
there's a piano in the
band, and there's also
drums and other stuff.
But there's, I don't know.
Yeah, piano rock.
Sometimes we say
indie piano rock
because we wear skinny jeans.
[LAUGHTER]
And it all balances out.
AARON ZEMACH: Right.
And so after DC, you moved
to Philadelphia for a bit.
And now you're here,
based out of Brooklyn
for the past seven or eight
years we figured out earlier.
And at what point in that
process did you realize, oh,
being a touring,
recording band is
going to be our full-time
lives from now on?
BEN THORNEWILL: That sort
of happened fairly quick out
of college.
So when we started
playing in college,
we were playing shows
to friends and it's just
sort of anyone we can get,
and we're flyering the campus.
And then, right towards
end of our senior year,
people that weren't our
friends started showing up.
And that's when we're like, all
right, let's give this a go.
And then moved to Philly and
had like a four bedroom house
for like $1,100 or something.
Appallingly cheap.
And then just started
touring and made just enough
to survive because we were in
the house that cost nothing.
And then that's sort
of been the case,
and we just kept doing it.
And the one thing that
always made sense for us
as we were trying to
make a career out of this
is when we toured, that's
how we made fans and got
in front of people.
It was-- I don't
think it's really ever
been a conscious decision.
We've just always kept
doing whatever worked.
And what happened to work was
playing shows and touring.
AARON ZEMACH: Mm-hmm.
BEN THORNEWILL:
That sound right?
TOMMY SIEGEL: Correct.
BEN THORNEWILL: OK.
AARON ZEMACH: Good answer.
Good answer.
Let's check.
OK, that was the correct answer.
And so you've been
going-- now you're
releasing your fifth studio
album March 30th, "Off
To The Races."
What would you say about
this album has been new
and an evolution of the band?
And what parts of
it would you say
are sort of like the core,
consistent music that
is Jukebox the Ghost?
TOMMY SIEGEL: So a
little background
I think on this record--
that is more important than I
think we knew going into it--
is that we, for
the last few years,
on Halloween, we've been doing
a show called Halloqueen, where
we play a set of our own stuff,
and then we get into costume
and come out and play a full set
of Queen dressed up as Queen.
And having to do a deep dive
into Queen's catalog for three
years in a row, I think it
had a bigger influence on us
than I think any of us
would have really imagined.
Because what we
realized is we sort of
hedge our bets
sometimes in terms
of whether we're making
something that's weird
or something that's
poppy, and sometimes we
sort of split the difference.
And what we ended up
really enjoying about Queen
is that they're really
catchy and they are so weird.
Like everything about
them is bizarre.
Like even the hits you think
are normal, when you actually
go back and listen to them,
the harmonies, the guitar
solos, the structures.
So I think for us,
it was the first time
we'd had a band that
we could reference
for creative decisions.
Like should we do that?
I don't know.
That might be a little weird.
But Queen did it.
You know?
And we could reference
them for everything.
So if we wanted a big harmony
stack, we went for it.
If we wanted a big guitar
solo, we went for it.
If we thought this song should
have 50 different parts all
jumbled together, we did it.
And it's not as
if we were trying
to sound like Queen exactly.
It's more that I think they
were like our spiritual guide
in letting us give
less of a crap
than we normally do
about pop preconceptions.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah,
I can definitely
hear in like
"Jumpstarted," which
was one of the singles you
released that Queen influenced,
or "Everybody's Lonely," too.
And so I guess, starting from
that point of this inspiration
from Queen, what
does the process look
like for a standard
Jukebox the Ghost song?
We have an idea,
what's the journey that
takes before it ends up
recorded and on an album?
BEN THORNEWILL: Every song
sort of has its own path.
I think Tommy and I both
write and then bring it
to the band in different states
of development or conception.
Like "Jumpstarted,"
which is one we just
released a couple of weeks
ago, depending on when
you're listening to this.
It was a demo that
I built out at home
and added endless,
seemingly endless, vocals.
And just everyday
I'd sit down and try
to add another part
without considering
what happened before
and never really thought
it'd be a Jukebox tune.
But that is a good example.
We brought it to
the band, and we all
started arranging and
thinking about it.
And they're like, this
should be a Jukebox tune.
And I'm like, this
is totally spastic
and completely unlistenable.
I don't think this
is a great idea.
But it ended up working out.
And it's filled with harmony
stacks and guitar solos.
But every song has its own path.
But--
TOMMY SIEGEL: And
this record is--
another thing that
separates this record
from our other records
is that in the past,
if we had a demo
or something, it
would be some rough recording
from the practice space
or an iPhone memo or something.
In this record, I think if
you went through and listened
to our demos from
the record, they're
pretty much the same as what we
ended up with on the recording,
just with more life and
more bells and whistles.
But we've all kind of become
more serious studio engineers
and producers on our own time
in the last three or four
years in a way that's starting
to really become meaningful
now.
AARON ZEMACH: And
so another song
I am specifically interested in.
I heard there's a track
on this album, Ben,
where you recorded 170
different vocal parts
and put them all together.
BEN THORNEWILL: Yeah.
AARON ZEMACH: What
does that mean?
And what's the story
behind trying that out?
BEN THORNEWILL: That was--
so sometimes when I write,
I'll sit either at the piano
or, in this case,
at the computer.
And it was for that
song, "Jumpstarted."
And I'd record a part, and
I don't think about it.
Like, I have a lead
vocal line and then
I just start
stacking and adding.
And so it'll just be--
for whatever reason, instead
of like a snare drum,
I'll go like (SINGING) ah.
And then I'll do (SINGING) baa.
And I'll do it 18 different
times, 18 different ways,
stacked on top of itself.
And so the way that
that song ended up
with like 170
different vocal tracks
is because I would do
these 15-part harmonies,
vocal stacks, all over the song,
all with different effects,
all with different levels.
And it worked.
And now we're having a lot
of trouble figuring out
how to do that live.
I'll tell you.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's funny.
We brought it into the
studio to actually record it,
and we uploaded all these
tracks to the session,
and it immediately crashed.
And the producers were
like, you can't do this.
You have to make-- so we
did, you know, compressed it.
But it's all in there.
But I like using the voice and
the ability to record and layer
the voice on top of itself as
an instrument all to itself.
You have the lead
vocal, and then you
have the harmonies
or all the textures
or other ways of
working with vocals.
TOMMY SIEGEL: And there's
harmonies on the record,
too, that--
what's a fun coincidence--
like usually,
Ben and I both sing lead and
kind of trade off on songs.
And on this record--
in prior records, you could
really tell the difference,
I think, more between our songs.
And this record you can
too, if you know the band.
But it just felt like
a fun coincidence
that we were both
really, really into thick
harmony stacks on this record.
That's a fun commonality
throughout the whole thing.
AARON ZEMACH: Mm.
Mm-hmm.
I guess it also makes me think--
I have been seeing you
perform live for probably
about eight years.
And as the group's evolved--
we love technology
here at Google,
and you've been incorporating
more and more technology,
drum pads and synths and
live looping and more guitar
effects.
Is that something that you've
made a conscious choice
that you're interested
in to change your sound?
Or just a natural evolution
of what you've been doing?
BEN THORNEWILL: I think whenever
we add something technological
to our otherwise
basic live show,
it's just to get
across something
that we did on the record that
we have no other way of doing.
So if I have a looper
pedal, I'll hit it.
And in a set amount of
time, it will just loop.
And whenever I sing, it will
add that on top of itself.
And so you can use that
as a way to falsify
having an eight-part harmony
and just build it live,
and it exists there.
Or if there's like
a, I don't know.
Jesse, what do you
trigger on that thing?
JESSE KRISTIN: I think a snap.
I can't even snap myself,
so it has to be a sample.
BEN THORNEWILL: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
TOMMY SIEGEL: We're also
considering just sucking, too.
We haven't-- we're still
working it out, so.
AARON ZEMACH: I'm interested
to hear how that goes.
[LAUGHTER]
So we've been talking a
lot about live performing.
You've done over 1,000 shows,
which feels ridiculous.
And recently, you released
a live album of your music.
What inspired you
to want to release
some of that as an artifact?
BEN THORNEWILL: I think a lot
of that was because we played
so many shows, and we're like--
and for so long, people would
come to shows and be like,
I love your records, but we
like your live show better,
which is tiresome
but understandable.
And every time we make a record,
we think, well, maybe this one.
Maybe this one
they'll like better.
But we wanted to
sort of document
where we were at that time.
And we had four
records under our belt,
and that was a
long period of time
and a lot of material to cover.
And we wanted to document and
honor the live arrangements
that we've been honing and
developing over the years.
AARON ZEMACH: Mm-hmm.
What's that balance
like for you guys?
Do you prefer being on the
road, being in the studio?
A little of both?
JESSE KRISTIN: My answer,
what I tell people,
is I think Jukebox
the Ghost is a--
we're not a studio band
in a typical sense.
I think there are
bands that are born out
of the studio environment.
And the three of
us, we learned how
to play together just by
playing for our friends.
And that really just
kept snowballing,
and we were just tour more.
And I think that really
created our sound.
And then when it's time to
record our music, we record it.
But I'd say that we're
primarily a live band
and that does
inform our records.
BEN THORNEWILL: But they're also
two totally different beasts.
I mean, when you're
in a studio, you
can spend an entire day,
without exaggeration,
on 10 seconds of music.
And even that, it still
doesn't sound like anything
at the end of the day.
You've just done
170 vocal tracks.
And then-- but live is sort
of this whole other realm
of existence where
it's not creative in
the conventional musical sense.
You're there to put on a
show and travel and meet
people and do the thing and--
TOMMY SIEGEL: Yeah, I'm always
confused by others like us.
I've seen shows where the band's
like people have been talking,
and they'd be like, shh.
(WHISPERING) And you're like,
I'm expressing myself up here.
And I guess I kind of understand
that, but maybe we've performed
our songs too many times.
But I'm like the expressing
myself part was years ago.
Now we're putting on
a vaudeville show,
and I don't really care
if you talk or not.
[LAUGHTER]
So yeah.
I find that kind of funny.
AARON ZEMACH: Another thing
I have to ask about since
we're talking about the
live album is "Hold it In!
(Foot in Mouth Disease),"
the bonus release.
Would you mind describing
for everyone who might not
be familiar with this?
BEN THORNEWILL: Jesse, why
don't you take this one.
TOMMY SIEGEL: Jesse made
this album, by the way.
This is entirely his creation.
JESSE KRISTIN: I had some time
on my hands after that big tour
we did to make the record.
And so we recorded every
show from the record,
and we can only pick one
song per show for the record.
But there was so much banter
for an entire two month tour.
Just so much banter.
So what I would do is I
would have the track open
and I would look for the
gap between the songs.
So here's a wave form,
here's a wave form.
And then I would just
turn up the volume
and listen to whatever these
guys said to the audience.
And I just listened to
every show and every gap,
and I just compiled all the
most ridiculous moments.
And I--
BEN THORNEWILL: I have a long
history of really messing up
from a conversational
standpoint on stage
because I get too comfortable,
and then my mind wanders.
And when you're on like show
22, and you're in Des Moines,
and it just all falls apart.
TOMMY SIEGEL: What's
amazing about Ben
is that he gets
nervous if you tell
him to call a pizza place--
BEN THORNEWILL: I hate it.
TOMMY SIEGEL: --and just
order a pepperoni pizza.
He can't do it.
But if you put him in front of
2,000 people with a microphone,
he's like, let me tell you about
the most embarrassing thing
that's ever happened to me.
[LAUGHTER]
BEN THORNEWILL:
And I don't realize
how bad it is until Jesse
went through and cataloged
150 moments.
JESSE KRISTIN: I think
it's 140 track album.
Most songs are about 20 seconds.
TOMMY SIEGEL: ITunes wouldn't
load it or something, right?
Because it was too many tracks?
JESSE KRISTIN: Somehow
I figured it out.
I, you know.
AARON ZEMACH: I mean, as a fan,
it was quite a great treat.
And you guys have such a really
neat connection with your fans
directly.
One way specifically that
I wanted to talk about,
Tommy, are your Van Doodles.
I think we actually have
some visuals to show.
Could you describe for people
who might not be familiar what
the Van Doodles you do are?
TOMMY SIEGEL: So yeah.
Through our band social media,
I'll take drawing requests
when we're on tour.
So a fan will tweet
like, you know-- oh,
is there something up there?
OK.
AARON ZEMACH: Yup, we got it up.
TOMMY SIEGEL: A dinosaur
living out his dream of flying.
Aka a dinoSoar.
OK.
And then I'll draw it and
tweet it back at them.
But it's something
everyone can see.
It's not like it's a
totally private exchange.
Nicolas Cage playing-- yeah.
Nicolas Cage as both
Romeo and Juliet.
Jesse as Pennywise the clown.
[LAUGHTER]
This is a good selection.
Very nice.
AARON ZEMACH: I think we have
a bunch here of different ways
that you've drawn the band.
TOMMY SIEGEL: Yeah, different
ways of drawing the band.
And so this is a funny-- a
funny thing that I've noticed
is that we used to get
fan art pretty regularly.
Like there were people who would
do fan art of us as something.
And then I started doing these,
and that totally dried up.
And I think it's because all
of a sudden, we in-sourced fan
art.
Like it's totally
in-house now, so they
don't have to do it anymore.
Which makes me feel a
little strange, but--
yeah, there's us as Charlie
Brown, or "the Great Pumpkin,
Charlie Brown," specifically.
AARON ZEMACH: So if someone
is listening to this video
and they want to figure out
what's the way that I can give
a tweet that Tommy is going
to see and fulfill my request,
is there like a secret sauce
of what you look for when
you're pulling tweets off?
TOMMY SIEGEL: Of
what I look for?
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah.
TOMMY SIEGEL: Well,
the ones I don't do
are the ones that are
like (SINGING) draw me.
Because I'm like,
I don't know you.
[LAUGHTER]
But otherwise, if they leave
enough room for it to be funny,
then I want to draw it.
If it's something that is
just too specific for anybody
to understand, then
I typically don't.
But I don't know.
I've done so many.
I mean, I've probably
done a couple of thousand
at this point or something.
AARON ZEMACH: Wow.
And you have a book
of them, right?
That you--
TOMMY SIEGEL: Yeah,
a few years ago, I
put out like a little zine.
It's not really a super
fancy book, but just
a compilation of the first
couple of years of doing it.
But it's totally
snowballed since then.
It's been a--
I mean, as you guys probably
know about social media,
it is very photocentric.
And one of the weird
things about being
a musician in the social media
era is that listening to a song
takes time and patience.
And you're going to have to
have somebody's total focus
to really get their attention.
Which is like the opposite of
what social media was built
for, which is like this sort
of instantaneous ephemera
of scrolling.
So what we found is that
stuff like the drawings
is a way to maintain a
connection with our fans
on social media in a way that's
not too forced or narcissistic
or something, and
hopefully still draw people
into the music.
Because I mean, if we're
posting a song on Facebook,
it's really tough for our song--
even if they're a big fan
of music, it's tough for us
to compete with Kim Kardashian
and Trump and all these things
that are occupying the
same space as music now.
Whereas it used to be music
was you go to the record store
and you look at your
records and you're
competing with other music.
But we are competing
with Kim Kardashian, so.
We're trying to win,
and we're in it to win.
BEN THORNEWILL: She is
a fierce competitor.
[LAUGHTER]
AARON ZEMACH: And so with
this social media presence,
you're fairly active across
all different channels,
and a lot of it feels
very spontaneous.
And so as a band
who's using this
as a promotional venue, how
much of your social media
is strategies that
you think through?
How you're going to engage your
fans, cultivate an audience.
And how much of it is
just what's on your mind
and just popping
up in your heads?
BEN THORNEWILL: We
outsource most of it.
[LAUGHTER]
No, it's a mix.
We sort of developed this voice.
A lot of it came from the all
caps guy of a couple of years
ago.
And we just write
terrible, ridiculous things
in all caps with terrible
syntax and grammar.
TOMMY SIEGEL: And it
used to be like an only
late night at a bar
kind of a posting thing.
But now it's just sort of become
an all hours of the day voice
for our--
this is specifically
Twitter I should say.
Facebook, we have a--
we use capitalization--
AARON ZEMACH: But now it's
proper capitalization.
TOMMY SIEGEL: Proper
capitalization, punctuation.
Instagram may be
a little sloppier.
And then Twitter is just an
emoji, all caps landfill.
BEN THORNEWILL: It's
a total free-for-all.
AARON ZEMACH: So we
are going to start
taking audience questions
in just a minute if people
want to start lining up.
While they do, though,
one more question.
I guess as a result of having
this social media presence--
and you're very
engaged with your fans.
I see you at the merch table
after pretty much every show.
Do you have any
particular memories
of interactions
with a fan that have
been meaningful in
some important way
or maybe crazy and unfortunate
in any particular way
that stand out in your head?
BEN THORNEWILL: You get both.
I mean, you have
the moments where--
let me phrase it like this.
You forget that, or
as I often forget,
that music can have such
an actual, legitimate,
life-changing impact.
You know, you write
the song and then
you spend all this time
recording it and arranging it,
and we're in a van and we're
traveling and we're driving.
And all the detail, all the
mess, sort of takes over.
And then you meet
somebody after show
who, without sort
of overexaggerating,
found a song at a time in
their life when they needed it.
You know?
And you get that feedback
of, for them, it's
like that saved my life.
Like it was there for a really
important part in my life.
And that's a really
beautiful thing
that can happen and sort of
pull me or any of us back in.
Be like oh, right.
We're doing this for a
reason and this is great.
And then you have
people come up and be
so touchy-feely and grabby and
think they know you and try
to get you to their house.
[LAUGHTER]
And so you just
don't know who you're
going to talk to at the
end of a show, which
is why we always go out.
[LAUGHTER]
AARON ZEMACH: Great.
Well, while we're
waiting for questions,
we talked about Queen and
how big an influence that was
for you guys.
If you had to choose another
artist or musician that you
feel like right now is being
a big influence on the music
you're creating, what
other artists come to mind?
TOMMY SIEGEL: So this is
sort of a cop out answer,
but I've been thinking about
this as this record has
been finally finished.
Is that usually with
a record, I feel
like we've explored a sound and
I'm ready for the next thing.
And what to me is fun about
this record is I'm like, well,
I could make another
record like that tomorrow.
So honestly, I
think it really felt
like we cracked something
new open with this record
that we're going
to keep exploring.
AARON ZEMACH: Awesome.
So we have a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks a lot for coming and
just for being a great band.
We've been to a lot
of your live shows
and really love your music.
BEN THORNEWILL: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So kind of
a two-part question.
Since you've done
so many live shows,
I'm curious is there
a song that you
love performing live the most?
And then is there one that maybe
you don't hate performing it,
but it's most loved by
crowds but you're like,
well, we could stop playing
that and I'd be happy about it.
BEN THORNEWILL: I think before
I get into specifics, each of us
has a song that we
never want to play,
and it's always a conversation.
There's a song called
"The Popular Thing," which
is from our second record.
And not to throw you--
JESSE KRISTIN: No.
BEN THORNEWILL:
But Jesse hates it.
He doesn't ever want to play it.
JESSE KRISTIN:
No, I don't like--
BEN THORNEWILL: He
likes the song--
JESSE KRISTIN: --playing it.
I like the song.
BEN THORNEWILL: Never
wants to play it--
JESSE KRISTIN: I
don't want to play it.
BEN THORNEWILL: And it's such
a played out conversation
that it's not
worth the argument.
We never play it.
TOMMY SIEGEL: I mean,
it's become a running joke
right before we go
on stage is like,
want to throw
"Popular Thing" in?
BEN THORNEWILL: Yeah, let's
do "The Popular Thing."
JESSE KRISTIN: We're about
to get so many requests
for "Popular Thing.
[LAUGHTER]
Killing me.
BEN THORNEWILL:
But then there are
songs that sort of all--
for me, "Good Day," which
is the first from
our first record.
I always love playing it.
It feels special, it feels
emblematic of everything
that we've done, and it always--
it works, for whatever reason.
So that stays with me.
TOMMY SIEGEL: We always pull
songs in and out of rotation,
too, or try to anyway.
Like "Hold It In," I think
we were all really, really,
really sick of.
And then we stopped-- we haven't
played it for like two years,
and now we're playing it again.
And we're like,
ah, this is great.
It's so easy.
JESSE KRISTIN: Those breaks are
good though because for Ben,
he's played a song
so many times,
he'll forget the
lyrics, somehow.
Because it's like
that comfort zone.
So you've got to give "Hold
It In" a break, or "Victoria."
TOMMY SIEGEL: The
one song I'm not
sure is ever going to get
old for me playing live
is "Hollywood," which is like--
AUDIENCE: Yes, yes.
TOMMY SIEGEL: Yeah, right?
I mean, it's just like--
it was like the first time
we played that song live,
it was just so obvious that
we were never not going
to play it ever again.
BEN THORNEWILL: For those
of you that don't know,
Jesse comes out and croons to
the audience like a jazz lounge
singer for that song.
JESSE KRISTIN: I
don't hate that one.
I don't mind it.
[LAUGHTER]
We're good.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
AARON ZEMACH:
Question over here?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I've been listening to your
music for I guess a while.
And one of the things that keeps
me coming back to the albums
and sharing them with
my friends is not only
the sound, which I really
like, but the narratives
and the stories behind
songs and albums.
Some of them are really
apocalyptic, you know?
And so I was
wondering if you could
talk a little bit about
a narrative or a story
behind an album?
Either an old one
or this new one.
TOMMY SIEGEL: Well, I know
the narrative thing, I think,
is particularly evident
on our first record.
For those who don't know,
it's called "Let Live
and Let Ghosts."
And that record was--
we were away from each other in
college for the only like nine
month period that we were away
from each other in college
at all, and when
Ben was gone, you
wrote "Good Day,"
and "Victoria--"
BEN THORNEWILL: "Victoria."
TOMMY SIEGEL: "--Hold It In."
You wrote-- I mean
all those songs were
from that period of time.
And the same thing
happened for me,
but I was maybe being
a little OCD about it
and was writing a
full concept album
about the apocalypse,
which we then
divided up and trimmed down and
put parts of it on "Let Live
and Let Ghost."
But yeah, I was very
much a concept album guy
at that point in time.
And you can definitely hear
that on the first two records.
Yeah.
The new record, by the
way, if anybody's curious,
is not a concept
record though, which
I'm sorry to disappoint
anybody who was
hoping for our quadrophenia.
JESSE KRISTIN: All the songs
are about horses, but--
[LAUGHTER]
TOMMY SIEGEL: Not a plot.
It's just they're
all about horses.
BEN THORNEWILL:
It's just horses.
JESSE KRISTIN: Coincidence.
BEN THORNEWILL: Yup.
AARON ZEMACH: All right.
Thanks.
Question over here?
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
Thanks for coming.
I was wondering if--
you said so this album
is more sort of free form
and experimental, maybe.
Did you write anything in the
past that maybe resurfaced now
that didn't make
sense at the time
but now makes sense with
this more free form thing
that you're doing?
BEN THORNEWILL: Yeah.
I mean, it's funny.
I think rarely-- we always--
whenever a song doesn't make it
on an old record,
we always think,
that's going to be
on the next record.
And it's never happened.
And we are always holding
on to these songs.
I think you take,
or at least I take--
and probably Tom takes, too--
like little pieces or
ideas from old songs
or structural concepts that
are out there and recycle them.
Because a lot of it ends up--
when you're writing a record
and then picking the songs for
the record, there's two parts.
We came into the record with
30, 40, 50 songs, something
like that, and then picking
the songs that we think
are going to work
the best together.
And I think when you're
writing, you always think,
no matter what, the
last thing you wrote
is the best thing
you've ever written,
and you're probably never going
to write another song again
in your life.
Like that's sort of the balance.
And so I don't
know if we've ever
actually taken a
song from the past
and successfully
brought it back.
TOMMY SIEGEL: I don't think so.
But I was thinking
about, recently, there's
a song that we used to play
in college that I was mentally
coming back to it for the
first time in like 12 years
and thinking, that
kind of could work now.
But it didn't-- for
whatever reason,
it wasn't working
for us in 2008.
But that's the first time
I've had that thought
in I think our entire career.
So maybe in the future.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BEN THORNEWILL: Yeah.
AARON ZEMACH: Over here.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: Since
you're here at Google,
and you mentioned
social media, I
wanted to kind of flip the
script and hear from you.
What's something that Google
and YouTube could do better
to engage with
up-and-coming music
creators such as yourselves?
BEN THORNEWILL: Interesting.
TOMMY SIEGEL: I think something
that would be interesting
would be to see if there is a
way to give music its own zone.
I just think it's not--
it's a space that's designed
for visuals and video and text,
and I think that
trying to compete
in that space with
audio is just--
I don't think there is like
an algorithmic solution.
I think it needs its
own space because people
need a different mental
space to explore music
than they do pictures of food.
And right now, we're competing
with pictures of food.
BEN THORNEWILL:
And Kim Kardashian.
TOMMY SIEGEL: And Kim
Kardashian, and pictures
of Kim Kardashian eating food.
So I would be
interested to see what
it would look like if Google
and Facebook and others maybe
tried to respect art in
its own space that is not
the same as the space that
pictures and advertising takes
up.
Because I guess my
feeling as a musician
is that the online
space sort of assumes
that we have the capital and
the resources of like Walmart
for advertising to
our own fan base.
And the return on
music, it's just not
the same financial return
as it is for things that
are selling physical products.
So I'd be interested to see
a space that allows music
to be in its own world.
I think that would be fun.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
AARON ZEMACH: Over here?
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
I'll ask two just
totally unrelated things.
The first one being are we going
to hear more of Jesse singing
on this new album?
Now that he broke
out with Hollywood
and has his own
kind of solo album?
And then the second one
being about the fan art.
As someone who's
actually made some,
I'm still trying to figure out
if it's just weird and creepy
or like endearing.
And I'm curious what your
take is on that as well.
TOMMY SIEGEL: Well,
I guess my question
for you would be do
you think it's creepy
that we make our own fan
art for our own band?
AUDIENCE: No, I love it.
I'm pretty egocentric myself.
[LAUGHTER]
BEN THORNEWILL: Is it
creepy when I sing?
[LAUGHTER]
JESSE KRISTIN: No, this--
well, I don't want
to spoil it too much.
But on this record, I'll
be singing background
vocal parts more than
previous records.
But there is not a
Hollywood-like moment
on this one.
That isn't to say that--
BEN THORNEWILL: The next
record won't be all you.
TOMMY SIEGEL: I feel--
JESSE KRISTIN:
[INAUDIBLE] all me.
TOMMY SIEGEL: I feel
his Phil Collins
moment just like swelling
and ready to arrive.
That's how I feel.
BEN THORNEWILL: But as
far as the fan art thing,
we still love it.
I think when-- and Tommy
was saying it dried up.
But that's not something
that we're happy about.
I mean, it's like,
oh, they've stopped
sending us stuff or making--
we want-- we love that
because we too are egocentric.
And the more we can see
of us, about us, is great.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
I'll keep it up then.
BEN THORNEWILL: Yeah, thanks.
AARON ZEMACH: Awesome.
Well, thanks for the questions.
It's been so great
talking, but would you guys
mind if we clear the stage
and we can hear a few songs?
Think that would be great.
BEN THORNEWILL:
Yeah, we'll do it.
AARON ZEMACH: Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - JUKEBOX THE GHOST,
"EVERYBODY'S LONELY"]
BEN THORNEWILL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TOMMY SIEGEL: So this is another
song from our new record,
and it's about growing
up, getting older.
And it's called "Boring."
[MUSIC - JUKEBOX THE GHOST,
"BORING"]
[APPLAUSE]
BEN THORNEWILL: Thank you.
So we have one more song left.
Thank you all so
much for being here
and listening and asking
questions and giving us
tricky water bottles.
All sorts of stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
This last one's
called "Fred Astaire."
[MUSIC - JUKEBOX THE GHOST,
"FRED ASTAIRE"]
Thank you all so much.
[APPLAUSE]